[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Music]
the question this year is could europe
survive without russian gas the answer
to this question can be found in a piece
of news that has gone almost unnoticed
but is very important just a day before
putin entered ukraine he had this
meeting
russian azerbaijani presidents to meet
in moscow on tuesday and i know many of
you will be thinking what does the
president of azerbaijan have to do with
this story well actually a lot in
today's video we're going to tell you
about two countries that until now were
practically unknown but are likely to be
talked about a lot in the future but
let's get back to the question that we
said at the beginning can europe really
stop buying natural gas from russia by
now i think you all know that europe
needs russian gas to survive more than
40 of the natural gas consumed in the
entire european union comes from russia
and with or without war in ukraine
everything indicates that the kremlin
wants to keep selling in fact at the
time of making this video with russian
tanks on the streets of kiev gasprom
pipelines were still pumping gas to the
european union and i know what you're
thinking right now what economic
sanctions can we put on russia if we
keep buying gas from them as long as
europe remains the main buyer the
russian economy will continue to receive
money
in other words european politicians can
continue to make speeches worthy of
churchill himself but these are all
cheap slogans if we continue to finance
putin's war and it is precisely the hot
air that has brought us to this very
situation in fact since the war broke
out in ukraine dependence on russia has
actually increased and i know what some
of you are thinking let's make the
sacrifice let's just stop buying gas
from russia if necessary we'll spend the
rest of the winter without heating but
the truth is that we use natural gas for
everything industry agriculture
electricity production so come on to
play the martyr and say that we can live
without gas today is kind of more cheap
slogans and i think that by now we're
kind of all a bit fed up with cheap
slogans aren't we so the real question
that we are asking today is could europe
really stop depending on russian gas and
is there any alternative to the current
european energy policy today we're going
to answer all of these questions but
first many of you have asked us if there
is a way to help ukraine in this war and
the truth is that there is the national
bank of ukraine is accepting donations
from all over the world to support the
resistance and ukrainian armed forces
this is not an advertising plug nobody
is paying us to say this and it is
merely informative if you're interested
you can find the link in the description
below but now let's take a look at some
history
[Music]
packed with the devil
[Music]
i am going to say it very clearly part
of what is happening now in ukraine is
due to germany's energy policy i know
what i just said is controversial but
the data is there up to the time of
making this video germany has been
blocking the shipment of armaments to
ukraine check this out
germany okay's weapons for ukraine in
major shift on military aid until
saturday germany had a long-standing
practice of blocking lethal weapons from
being sent to conflict zones in any case
in any discussion about russia germany
is always the country closest to the
kremlin and why might you ask quite
simply at the end of the long road of
cheap slogans is the most cynical real
politique let me explain germany is the
largest energy consumer in europe this
makes sense if we take into account that
it is the largest economy in the entire
european union the cheap slogans germany
does not want nuclear nor does it want
coal nor does it want oil and green
energies are not insufficient there is
no way to store energy today yes it is
true there are experimental technologies
for storing energy but for the time
being they're still in the laboratory
that leaves gas and that is why both
germany and europe are consuming more
gas than ever before
in 1990 they produced 40 000 gigawatts
of power by gas by 2020 they were
producing more than 94 000 gigawatts it
is true that in relative terms gas
represents a smaller percentage of the
mix but in absolute terms europeans are
buying more and more and more gas and
russia is their main supplier think of
it this way politically speaking russian
gas is the good nice and cheap energy
option good because it pollutes less
than coal nice because it provides
energy whenever we need it and cheap
because it comes from russian pipelines
which are nearby and have good prices
does it mean that we've made a pact with
the devil yes but until now who cared we
have seen demonstrations against climate
change and nuclear energy but who was
demonstrating against putin hardly
anyone
let's put it bluntly prior to february
2022 putin and a war in ukraine was
something that only those of you who
watched visualpolitik and a handful of
others worried about no one in germany
was losing elections for having a close
relationship with putin in fact we've
all seen raul gonzalez playing soccer
for schalke in a gazprom jersey and no
one thought it was bad and all of this
explains why instead of looking for
other gas suppliers germany has been
looking for ways to buy even more gas
from russia without it having to go
through ukraine unfair yes but then
again how many of you have heard of
nordstrom 2 and that's how we get to
february 2022 what happens now well
check this out
[Music]
adept to the devil
the first consequence of this war with
ukraine is that nordstrom 2 has been
paralyzed until further notice this was
not an easy decision for germany but
really there was no other choice for the
time being russia continues to sell gas
to europe via ukraine the question is
until when and under what conditions pay
attention to what the deputy chairman of
the security council of russia dmitry
medvedev said on twitter
german chancellor olef schultz has
issued an order to halt the process of
certifying the nordstrom 2 gas pipeline
well welcome to the brave new world
where europeans are very soon going to
pay 2 000 euros for 1 000 cubic meters
of natural gas dimitri medvedev deputy
chairman of the security council of
russia the real question is no longer
whether we want to continue to depend on
russia the question is how do we reduce
that 40 of gas we buy from russia and
how can we do it as soon as possible at
the moment the united states has already
sent 60 liquefied natural gas tankers
with liquefied natural gas qatar had
said it'd be willing to sell some gas if
russia cuts off some supplies you're
probably thinking well problem solved
then well not at all really
firstly it's hard to imagine that united
states or qatar could supply all the gas
that comes from russia liquefied natural
gas is much more expensive than gas
arriving by pipeline if all of a sudden
all the big european industries had to
pay for gas at asian prices we would be
talking about a gigantic economic crisis
and the question is what can be done do
we go back to building nuclear reactors
i mean it doesn't seem very feasible it
takes almost 10 years to build a nuclear
reactor not to mention the lack of
political wealth do we expect that
renewable energies can be stored cheaply
i mean i've already told you about cheap
slogans are we going to make decisions
based on the promise that one day
someone will discover a new technology
that will change everything and so what
are our real options well check this out
new devils to make pacts with
we said at the beginning the era of
cheap slogans is over so let's call a
spade a spade europe has no choice but
to make pacts with new devils think of
it this way it is better to depend on
several levels than on just one so the
first devil in our story is the
gentleman you see on screen
[Music]
meet ilham aliev the president of
azerbaijan i know azerbaijan is one of
those countries you realize exists
mostly thanks to the eurovision song
contest
and believe me he is a savage corrupt
dictatorship not without geopolitical
problems if you don't believe me just
ask the armenians and this is where the
news story from the beginning of our
video fits in
russian azerbaijani presidents to meet
in moscow on tuesday this meeting took
place two days before the invasion of
ukraine both putin and aliyev declared
eternal love military cooperation and
understanding of all kinds the question
is is azerbaijan really russia's best
ally well the truth is that no it is not
first of all they compete with moscow
for selling gas but not only that
azerbaijan's main supporter is turkey a
nato member since 1952 and a historical
antagonist of russia besides being
famous for caviar azerbaijan is blessed
with one of the largest natural gas
fields in the world the famous shad
denise fields in the middle of the
caspian sea what's more as of 2020
azerbaijan has been selling natural gas
to europe take a look at this
map here you can see how gas travels
from the caspian sea to southern italy
construction started in may 2016 and was
completed in november 2020 in total four
years at the time this pipeline
generated a lot of controversy and yes
russian propaganda was involved to the
maximum in italy they even got the five
star movement the trending political
party at the time on their side but
nothing that transcended public opinion
in fact we've all seen tebow couture
winning the soccer league with his team
atletico de madrid wearing the shirt of
azerbaijan the land of fire no one ever
protested well thanks to this pipeline
europe can further diversify its supply
today
italy and azerbaijan plan to raise
trans-adriatic pipeline gas deliveries
and at this point you're probably
thinking what a move are we really going
to replace one terrible dictator with
another are we going to give up being
dependent on russia to become dependent
on azerbaijan well no relax because in
the select club of dictators with
natural resources there was a new player
someone no one expected and believe me
i'm sure no one saw this coming
meet turkmenistan this country doesn't
even participate in eurovision if you're
familiar with it it's maybe because of a
video we made on visualpolitik that
seemed more like a humorous monologue
than anything else in fact it's a video
that has a lot of views purely because
it is so terrible that is even funny the
dictator of this country is called
gurbanguli berdimine jibhama now dao the
name's gonna appear on the screen but he
is also known by his oppressed people as
archetag well mr archetag is the comic
version of kim jong-un
[Music]
to give you an idea he had a 68 foot
that's a 21 meter high gold statue built
of himself riding a horse actually the
statue is made of bronze but it is
covered with 24 karat gold if you think
having gold statues of yourself is not
enough he also had one built of his dog
in addition archetag also composes his
own rap songs and give concerts to his
people this is not a joke or i'm sorry
to say an exaggeration if it weren't for
the fact that we were talking about one
of the most oppressive regimes in the
world it would kind of look like an
episode of south park
however turkmenistan has the fourth
largest natural gas reserves in the
world and its only major buyer at the
moment is china
for several years they've been trying to
build a pipeline to sell to india this
pipeline is called the tapi tapi which
is an acronym for turkmenistan
afghanistan pakistan and india that's
right turkmenistan's economic future
depended on a gas pipeline that was to
pass through afghanistan as you can
imagine it is a pretty uncertain future
right now but i'm not saying it's going
to be built but as you can imagine at
the moment building anything in
afghanistan is a very complicated task
in other words mr arcad may be a
dictator but he has got natural gas and
he is desperate to sell it that explains
news stories like this
agreement between azerbaijan and
turkmenistan paves the way for
trans-caspian pipeline that's right if
you remember in the video we made about
turkmenistan hashtag bring back simon we
already told you that this country had
plenty of natural gas but we took it for
granted that this gas could never reach
europe however necessity is the mother
of invention and the solution is already
on the table
all that is needed is to connect
turkmenistan's gas to the pipeline that
already connects azerbaijan to italy and
walla europe will be connected to the
fourth largest natural gas reserves in
the world in addition to all this there
is another advantage turkmenistan has
check out this map
do you see what i see exactly
turkmenistan competes with russia in the
gas market but it has no border with
russia that is it is probably a
difficult country to invade and you're
probably thinking is it really possible
to start building gas extraction plants
in turkmenistan just think we are
talking about one of the most
underdeveloped places in the world
what's more is a dictatorship where
legal certainly is conspicuous by its
absence but let's be clear if the
political will is there anything is
possible at this point it is worth
remembering that 100 years ago saudi
arabia was not much better off than
turkmenistan is today
[Music]
of course this does not mean that europe
will stop buying gas from russia nor
does it mean that getting new suppliers
will solve all of its energy problems
but it does show that with political
will it is possible to start reducing
russian dependence and that's urgent so
the question is will there really be
political will this time well we really
see europe making a clear policy to stop
depending on russia and do you all think
this is a good idea and more importantly
will we see barcelona football team
putting the face of arcade their dear
leader on their shirts you can leave me
your answer in the comments below as
always don't forget that here on
visualpolitik we release new videos
every week so subscribe to this channel
and hit the little bell button down
there so you don't miss any of our
updates if you like this video like it
so we know and
i'll see you next time
you